es un momento histórico y el fin de una
era la monarca más longeva de reino
unido la reina isabel segunda ha muerto
a los 96 años después de reinar durante
70 años pocos días después de que la
reina la nombrará como primera ministra
liz tras expresó sus condolencias
a the news todos estamos desolados por
la noticia que acabamos de escuchar
desde balmoral la muerte de su majestad
la reina es una gran conmoción para la
nación y para el mundo la reina isabel
segunda fue la roca sobre la que se
construyó reino unido- el rock
el hijo mayor de isabel segunda carlos
encabezará un luto del país como nuevo
rey en un comunicado el rey carlos
tercero dijo que todo el mundo extrañar
a su madre
el fallecimiento de mi querida madre su
majestad la reina es un momento de
máxima tristeza para mí y para todos los
miembros de mi familia sé que su pérdida
se sentirá profundamente en todo el país
los reinos y la commonwealth y por
innumerables personas en todo el mundo
las banderas de todo reino unido- ondean
a media asta y el país ha entrado en un
periodo de luto nacional que durará diez
días la familia de la reina se trasladó
a escocia para estar a su lado a primera
hora del jueves después de las
advertencias de los doctores que desde
temprano se dijeron preocupados por su
estado de salud desde finales del año
pasado sufría constantes problemas de
movilidad que lo obligaron a cancelar
casi todos sus compromisos públicos la
reina isabel segunda llegó al trono en
1952 cuando apenas tenía 25 años